my name is Hannah and that is a
palindrome that is a word you can sell
spell it's a word you can spell the same
way forwards and backwards if you can
spell but the thing is my entire family
have palindromic names it's a bit of a
tradition
we've got mum dad men and my brother
kayak there you go that's just a bit of
a joke there um I like to kick things
off with the joke because I'm a comedian
now there's two things you know about me
already my name is Hannah and I'm a
comedian I'm wasting no time yeah here's
a third thing you can know about me I
don't think I'm qualified to speak my
own mind bold way to begin a talk yes
but it's true I've always had a great
deal of difficulty turning my thinking
into the talking so it seems a bit of a
contradiction then that someone like me
who's so bad at the chat could be
something like a stand-up comedian but
there you go there you go
it's what it is I just tried my hand at
stand-up comedian see see see
I first tried my hand at stand-up comedy
in my late 20s and despite being a
pathologically shy virtual mute with low
self-esteem who'd never held a
microphone before I knew as soon as I
walked and stood in front of the
audience I knew before I'd even landed
my first joke I knew but I really like
stand up and stand up really like me but
for the life of me I couldn't work out
why why is it I could be so good at
doing something I was so bad at I just I
couldn't work it I could not understand
it that is until I could now before I
explain to you why it is that I can be
good at something
I'm so bad at let me throw another
spanner of contradiction into the work
by telling you that as soon you know not
long after I worked out why that was I
decided to quit comedy and before I
explain that little oppositional cat I
just threw amongst the thinking pigeons
let me also tell you this quitting
launched my comedy career they really
launched it to the point where you know
after quitting comedy I became the most
talked-about comedian on the planet
because apparently I'm even worse at
making retirement plans when I am at
speaking my own mind
now all I've done up until this point
apart from giving over a spattering
of biographical detail is to tell you
indirectly that I have three ideas that
I want to share with you today and I've
done that by way of sharing three
contradictions one I am bad at talking I
am good at talking I quit I did not quit
three ideas three contradictions now if
you're wondering why there's only two
things on my so-called list of three
I remind you it is literally a list of
contradictions keep now the folks of Ted
advised me that with a talk of this
length it's best to stick with just
sharing one idea I said no now what
would they know no to explain why I have
chosen to ignore what is clearly very
good advice I want to take you back to
the beginning of this talk specifically
my palindrome joke now that joke uses my
favorite trick of the comedian trade the
rule of three whereby you make a
statement and then back that statement
up with a list
my entire family have palindromic names
mum
dead men pop the first two ideas on that
list create a pattern and that pattern
creates expectation and then the third
thing bam kayak what that's the rule of
three one two surprise ha ha now
now the rule of three is not only
fundamental to the way you know I do my
craft it is also fundamental to the way
I communicate so I won't be changing
anything for nobody not even Ted which I
will point out stands for three ideas
Technology Entertainment and
[Applause]
works every time doesn't it but you need
more than just jokes to be able to cut
it as a professional comedian you need
to be able to walk that fine line
between being charming and disarming and
I discovered the most effective way to
generate the amount of charm
I needed to offset my disarming
personality was through not jokes but
stories so my stand-up routines are
filled with stories stories about
growing up my coming-out story stories
about the abuse I copped for being not
only a woman but a big woman and the
masculine of center of woman if you
watch my work online check the comments
out below for examples of abuse now it's
time at that time in the talk where I
shift into second gear and I'm going to
tell you a story about everything I've
just said in the last few days of her
life my grandma was surrounded by people
a lot of people because my grandma was
the loving matriarch of a large and
loving family now if you haven't made
the connection already I am a member of
that family now I was lucky enough to be
able to say goodbye to my grandma on the
day she died but as she was already
cocooned within herself by then it was
something of a one-sided goodbye so I
thought about a lot of things things I
hadn't thought about in a long time like
the letters I used to write to my
grandma when I first started University
letters I filled with funny stories and
anecdotes that I embellished for her
amusement and I remembered how I
couldn't articulate the anxiety and fear
that filled me as I tried to carve my
tiny little life into a world that felt
far too big for me
but I remembered finding comfort in
those letters because I wrote them with
my grandma in mind but as the world got
more and more overwhelming and my
ability to negotiate it but worse not
better I stopped writing those letters I
just didn't think I had the life that
grandma would want to read about grandma
did not know I was gay and about six
months before she died out of nowhere
she asked me if I had a boyfriend now I
remember making a conscious decision in
that moment not to come out to my
grandmother and I did that because I
knew her life was drawing to an end and
my time with her was finite and I did
not want to talk about the ways we were
different I wanted to talk about the
ways we were connected so I changed the
subject and at the time it felt like the
right decision but as I sat witnessed to
my grandmother's life as it tapered to
its inevitable end I couldn't help but
feel I'd made a mistake not to share
such a significant part of my life but I
also knew that I'd missed my opportunity
and as grandma always used to say oh
well it's all part of a soup too late to
take the onions out now
and I thought about that and I thought
about how I had to deal with too many
onions as a kid growing up gay in a
state where homosexuality was illegal
and with that thought I could see how
tightly wrapped in the tendrils of my
own internalized shame I wants and with
that I thought about all my traumas the
violence the abuse my rape and with that
all that cluster of thinking a thought a
question kept popping into my mind to
which I had no answer what is the
purpose of my human out of anyone in my
family I felt the most akin to my
grandmother we share the most traits in
common well not so much these days
death really changes people but that is
my grandmother's sense of humor but the
person I felt most akin to in the world
was a mother a grandmother a great
grandmother a great-great grandmother me
I represented the very end of my branch
of the family tree and I wasn't entirely
sure I was still connected to the trunk
what was the purpose of my human the
year after my grandmother's death was
the most intensely creative of my life
and I suppose that's because at an end
my thought gather more than they scatter
my thought process is not linear I'm a
visual thinker I see my thoughts I don't
have a photographic memory and nor is my
head a static gallery of sensibly
collected think pieces it's more that
I've got this ever-evolving language of
hieroglyphics that I've developed and I
can understand fluently and think deeply
with but I struggle to translate I can't
paint draw sculpt or even happen - and
as for the written words I you know I
can I'm okay at it but it's a torturous
process of translation and I don't feel
it does the job and as far as speaking
my own mind like I said I'm not great at
it
speech has always felt like an
inadequate freeze frame for the
inside of me all this to say I've always
understood far more than I've ever been
able to communicate now about a year
before grandma died I was formally
diagnosed with autism
now for me that was mostly good news I
always thought that I couldn't sort my
life out like a normal person because I
was depressed and anxious but it turns
out I was depressed and anxious because
I couldn't sort my life out like a
normal person because I was not a normal
person and I didn't know it now this is
not to say I still don't struggle every
day is a bit of a struggle to be honest
but at least now I know what my struggle
is and getting to the starting line of
normal is not it my struggle is not to
escape the storm my struggle is to find
the eye of the storm
as best I can now apart from the usual
way a spectrum types find out calm
repetitive behaviors routine and
obsessive thinking I have another
surprising doorway into the eye of the
storm stand-up comedy and if you need
any more proof I'm neurodivergent yes I
am calm doing a thing that scares the
hell out of most people I'm almost dead
inside up here
diagnosis gave me a framework to which
to hang bits of me I could never
understand my misfit suddenly had a fit
and for a while I got giddy with the
newfound confidence I had in my thinking
but after grandma died that confidence
took a dive because thinking is how I
breathe and in that grief of thought I
could suddenly see with so much clarity
just how profoundly isolated I was and
always had been what was the purpose of
my human I began to think a lot about
how autism and PTSD have so much in
common and I started to worry because I
had both if I could ever be you know
could I ever untangle them I'd always
been told that the way out of trauma was
through a cohesive narrative I had a
cohesive narrative but I was still at
the mercy of my traumas they're all part
of my soup but the onions still stung
and at that point I realized that I'd
been telling my stories for laughs I've
been trimming away the darkness cutting
away the pain and holding on to my
trauma for the comfort of my audience I
was connecting other people through
laughs yet I remained profoundly
disconnected what was the purpose of my
human I did not have an answer but I had
an idea I had an idea to tell my truth
all of it not to share laughs but to
share the literal visceral pain of my
trauma and I thought the best way to do
that would be through a comedy show and
that is what I did I wrote a comedy show
that did not respect the punchline that
line where comedians are expected and
trusted to pull their punches and turn
them into tickles I did not stop I
punched through that line into the
metaphorical guts of my audience I did
not want to make them laugh I wanted to
take their breath away to shock them so
they could listen to my story and hold
my paint as
not as a mindless laughing mob and
that's what I did and I called that
shout in a net now many now many have
argued that Nanette is not a comedy show
and while I can agree it is definitely
not a comedy show those people are still
wrong because they have framed their
argument as a way of saying I failed to
do comedy I did not fail to do comedy I
took everything I knew about comedy or
the tricks the tools the know know how I
took all that and with it a broke comedy
you cannot break comedy with comedy if
you fail at comedy blessed be thy hammer
that
was not my point the point was not
simply to break comedy the point was to
break comedy so I could rebuild it and
reshape it reform it into something that
could better hold everything I needed to
share and that is what I meant when I
said I quit comedy now it's probably at
this point where you're going yeah cool
but what are the three ideas exactly
it's a bit vague I'm glad I pretended
you asked now I'm sure there's quite a
few of you who've already identified
three ideas smart crowd by all accounts
so I wouldn't be surprised at all but
you might be surprised to find out that
I don't have three ideas I told you I
had three ideas and that was a lie that
was pure misdirection and very funny
what I've done instead is I've taken
whole handfuls of my ideas as seeds and
I've scattered them all throughout my
talk and why did I do that
apart from shits and giggles it comes
down to something my grandma always used
to say it's not the garden
it's the gardening that counts and
Nanette taught me the truth for that
true isn't it expected by breaking the
contract of comedy and telling my story
in all its truth and pain that that
would push me further into the margins
of both life and art I expected that and
I was willing to pay that cost in order
to tell my truth but that is not what
happened the world did not push me away
it pulled me closer through an active
disconnection I found connection and it
took me a long time to understand that
what is at the heart of that
contradiction is also at the heart of
the contradiction as to why I can be so
good at something I am so bad at you see
in the real world
I struggle to talk to people because
my new I diversity makes it difficult
for me to think listen speak and process
new information all at the same time but
on stage I don't have to think I prepare
my thinks well in advance I don't have
to listen that is your job and I don't
really have to talk because strictly
speaking I'm reciting so all that is
left is for me to do my best to make a
genuine connection with my audience and
if the experiences Nanette taught me
anything it's that connection depends
not just on me you play a part
Nanette may have begun in me but she now
lives and grows in a whole world of
other minds minds I do not share but I
trust I am connected and in that she is
so much bigger than me
just like the purpose of being human is
so much bigger than all of us make of
that what you will thank you and hello
[Applause]